how do you know if an idea is worth
developing into a story I have a
sounding board who is I guess it's kind
of my secret weapon but he's he's
someone who's you know he's seen he's
seen all my short films and he's always
the first person I go to with with an
idea like even a treatment stage to be
like it was this any good or is this
like really terrible and if it is really
terrible can i salvage it you know is
there a way to make it better and it's
um it's a very good friend called Faisal
a Qureshi and he's he's a professional
screenwriter and he's based in the UK
he's also directed films and he I think
it's very important as a writer to be
able to show someone that you trust
something that you're not entirely sure
if it's any good or not because he know
he knows me well enough now that he
knows like he can be really harsh and
it's okay because at the end of the day
I just want to know if I'm wasting my
time or not and he has been very harsh
and I really appreciate it
because I have had instances where it's
like I've sent him a treatment and he'll
tell me what's wrong with it like in a
very kind of brutal way but then that's
good because it helps me figure out how
I can make it better and I have actually
been able to like make it better and
like get on to fellowships with
treatments that before he was like don't
think so yeah do you does he reciprocate
in terms of he send you his scripts he
does yeah
he has sent me his materials before so
definitely I think that that's so
important is to have someone because I
think definitely I always feel like in
this industry you only really get like
one chance to like impress people so you
want to send them you want to put your
best foot forward and that's why it's
important to have someone who whose
opinion you trust and whose craft you
you really admire and you recognize that
they're really talented and they're
really intelligent and you can just show
them like your worst stuff and they will
you know give you suggestions
and we'll tell you maybe what you could
do to make it a little bit better does
he ever ask you to be more harsh
oh yeah yeah like tell me that like I
don't like did he have to incur or
because I could see you not wanting to
hurt someone's feeling and yet he's like
you know like you're like just be honest
like please just like tell me because I
do I do always think like I don't want
to hurt anybody's feelings
yeah right yeah I think that'd be really
important to have a you know working
relationship or just a friendship with
someone where you could give them and
you know that they're not trying to
wound you to stop you but they're just
trying to help make you better I think
that's a rare thing to find absolutely
so that's why you know big shout out to
it's a faisal nice and i think someone
who kind of you know because they
they've read your previous work and they
seem like your previous films that they
kind of they they know what you're
trying to do and and because of that
they can tell you i know i think i know
what you're trying to do but you're
maybe you're not doing it the best way
that you could do it so let me just you
know ask you some questions and and you
know make some suggestions because i
think i know why you're trying to get i
think that's very important because i
mean there are some people who you just
don't understand your work and don't
understand your films and you know don't
want to maybe not the best people to get
feedback from how do you know personally
when your movie idea isn't working not
not so much if you've given it to
someone as a sounding board but
personally i think that it's when you
you yourself are writing it and you are
not excited by what you're writing i
think that i think you know that it's
working when you're like you know I
really want to keep you know I want to
keep going I want to know I personally
want to know what happens next but if
you're kind of like trudging through it
and you were like oh god I have to write
another five pages or I have to write
you know another another you know five
pit fight like you know five paragraphs
of this treatment if you yourself are
having that thought trust me whoever is
reading it it's gonna us about the same
thought of oh god I have to read another
five pages before this is over yeah have
you ever abandoned
and ID like you've been excited about it
for a little while and then realize your
heart wasn't in it
I think yet definitely but I think more
would like I mean I have had that with a
feature script yeah which I was like god
this is not working as a feature but I
managed to kind of recycle it into
something else
and then also short films like you know
if you if you've you know written a
short film script that was a
collaboration with with a friend and
then you applied to a lot of funding and
you just keep getting rejected and then
it's like okay well then let's just not
so the universe was telling you
something or you look it that way and
then you just move on to the next
project because that got funding okay
well then I'll just do that yeah
you